cousins attended this morning's out of
the darkness walk at sunset park mary
jane belliesa shares how the event
provides mental health support and
suicide prevention
shining a light on mental health that's
the goal for the out of the darkness
community walk it's all to support
suicide prevention students from desert
oasis say this community walk couldn't
have come at a better time as the
effects of the pandemic has increased
the feelings of loneliness and isolation
our friend i think over a year ago now
she committed suicide
during quarantine we had a mental health
week and they gave us options like this
they tell people to come to suicide
walks and they give us mental health
weeks according to the american
foundation for suicide prevention
suicide is the third leading cause of
death in ages 10 to 35 years old local
leaders and a number of community
resources in attendance saturday hope
this event will bring awareness and
address the stigma surrounding mental
health
just talk to people because you never
know who's feeling the same way as you
or who can relate to you for siblings
denise and meliss they are walking for
their brother scott and while they say
the pain of losing a loved one may never
go away
very hard even
eight years later
to process it still it's just such a
wound on your heart for the family
connecting and helping others is their
way of giving back this gives us a
chance to celebrate him
and to have the beautiful memories and
and then to reach out to others who may
be suffering mary jane balleza live
local now
the event also included opening remarks
from governor sislek as you saw there an
honor bead ceremony and a mile walk
around the park to honor those we have
lost to suicide